if you're ready to try out battlefield
one good news you'll get your chance
very soon the battlefield one public
beta begins on ps4 xbox one and pc on
Wednesday August 31st battlefield
insiders will get to play at some point
before that and you have until the 21st
to sign up for early access dice hasn't
said just how much of a head start
insiders will have just yet the beta
will feature the Sinai desert map which
was just shown off in battlefield ones
gamescom trailer the map supports
infantry skirmishes on the ground
dogfights in the air and a devastating
armoured train as for game modes you can
try out 64 player conquest mode and 24
player rush mode there's currently no
word on when the beta will end
battlefield wan launches on october 21st
but there are several ways to play it
early EA access members will get the
game on the 13th and buying the deluxe
edition gets you in on the 18th you can
expect more trailers and campaign info
before release day and for all the
biggest battlefield one news you're
already in the right place
you